welcome back everyone to episode five of
the speedrun series I am currently rated
638 on my speedrun account I'm keeping
my baby Rosen profile picture for now
and let's see what happens um I'm just
going to hop straight into a game so
let's get this party
started okay playing Johnny TR
good and yeah still sticking with E4
we have a King's
Pawn and we have Knight F6 okay are we
going to see the first Stafford Gambit
of the
speedrun um now Knight of six very
playable move it's the beginning of the
Petro defense there are a few options
for white like Knight C3 is completely
playable D4 is an interesting line uh
but the most principled move is to take
the pawn uh now a lot of beginners will
take here walking into Queen
E2 which can go very wrong for black
very quickly and I think we're going to
see uh
some some quick downfall of
black although okay with D6 it is a
little bit tricky because now both
Knights are hanging and I definitely
don't want to take this Knight although
do
I wait a minute I don't think I've seen
this position before I was thinking I
can play Knight
F3 which saves my knight leaves this
Knight attacked and pinned but if I play
Knight F3 there's Queen
E7 and black is actually
defending I want to note and I'll share
this in more detail after the game that
Queen E7 is actually a very interesting
line that was recently played at the US
Championship I guess a year ago by a
Wonder leing against favano car
um but that's that's a story for
later um yeah if I play Knight F3 Queen
E7 I'm not winning anything so I think
it makes sense to take the
Knight black is likely to take
back and then I'll go up a
pawn um I'll have a lot of interesting
things to
share after this game in terms of the
opening but for now um I happy to have
one pawn and I might as well trade
Queens like makes sense to simplify when
you're up
material and we essentially have a
queenless middle
game but I have the extra Center Pawn
black develops and attacks
it now there are a few ways to deal with
this threat
um I probably don't want to push because
that allows Knight B4 and then I have
two pawns hanging
so I can play Bishop E3 develop and
defend I could play
C3 could play Bishop B5 too to pin the
Knight there's a lot of acceptable moves
here I kind of like Bishop B5 I think
this is the more active
move getting ready to
Castle and in pinning the Knight I'm
essentially defending the
pawn and I was also setting
up a threat which black didn't really
deal with the threat is D5
which I think is almost winning a piece
I'm going to play D5 we'll see if uh my
opponent can come up with the best
response Knight can't legally move yeah
A6 is uh it's definitely the the way to
go to try and not lose a full piece for
black so if I take the Knight I lose the
bishop I could then win the pawn if I
can draw arrows I can take on
B7 and it looks like this is going to be
a a
trade now the other option is to play
Bishop
A4 but then black has
B5 and then I can take and then
take and black will wind up with double
A
pawns all of this Pawn on
C6 I don't want to take too much time
here I think I'm going to play Bishop A4
and then if
B5 I could also consider taking first
and then taking I think in most lines
I'm going to maintain the extra Pawn but
black is definitely succeeding in um
trying to fight
back and after after the dust settles
the C Pawn is going to be attacked so if
I play Bishop B3 then there's Knight D4
and rather not deal with
that if I take take take
take I'll be up two Pawns in that
position it looks nice let's go for
this I will say though that black might
be doing fine here like Bishop takes
C2 yeah now Bishop E4 is
coming there's also a threat of Bishop
takes B1 and Rook takes A2 so I I might
not even be objectively better here wow
after what I thought was a very dubious
opening from
black and do have to manage my
time okay there are a few options here I
can
Castle basically allow black to win back
the
pawn but it's really a matter of trying
to
develop I like the move of Bishop Bishop
F4
simply developing and attacking the C7
Pawn black hassles very quickly wow so
defending the pawn and threatening Rook
D1 uh so I do have to be very
careful I could play Knight
C3 I could also
Castle
um not sure if it makes a
difference like both moves I want to
play eventually I think I'll Castle
first just uring my King's not getting
punished in the
center but big Kudos is my opponent
for um for
definitely getting a very fine
position um even though I'm still up a
pawn life should still be okay we play
Rook C1 here saving the Rook supporting
the C
Pawn I do have to move a lot
quicker in the series I do like to take
my time to explain my moves but do have
to be conscientious of uh of time
management so Knight C3 very uh very
normal move just
developing
if B4 then I'll have to find a different
Square for the
Knight I'm realizing here it would be
really nice to open the a
file so I'm going to play
A4 like even though Queens are off the
board the black king is in danger of
getting mated like if take I'm already
threatening Maiden
one
Bishop G5 I was going to say that H6
didn't seem to have a purpose but I
guess black Was preparing this I think
I'm very happy to take the
bishop and then next move I'll take the
pawn and is black going to see my maiden
one threat
okay that's a
relief I keep my winning streak
alive up to 17 wins
now um yeah I think out of all my games
in this
series that was my toughest game
yet and I definitely want to take a few
moments
to go back and review cuz yeah at the
beginning I thought it was going to be
just uh
a one-sided landslide in my favor like
Queen need to a lot of beginners play
that F6 here and then walk into this
nasty Discovery where white wins the
queen um yeah there's no way to save the
black
queen but yeah after D6 this is somehow
playable for
black now I want to show this line Queen
E7 because this is a a very tricky
variation I guess it's called the
Damiano maybe Damiano variation of the
pet uh the idea of Queen E7 is after
takes there's Pawn
D6 and I think I featured this line in a
few videos a while ago if I can find
them I'll link them below um but the
idea of this line is black is winning
back the piece and there's a trap here
after D4 takes takes Knight C6
black wants to in back the pawn and I
actually had this position in a
tournament game several years ago back
when I was
and within two moves I was playing white
within two moves I was losing material I
played the the move Bishop F4 very
natural to develop and defend and then
my opponent hit me with
G5 I thought okay I just move back save
the
bishop but then this is already a big
mistake it's black to move here in win
material feel free to pause a video if
you want to find it uh but the move is
F5 and amazingly black is going to trap
my bishop and there's not much I can do
about it I can't up a sa CU then I lose
my queen um so this is a funny trap that
I thought maybe we could have transposed
into or at least we could have
transposed into
uh the queen E7 line because black has
Queen E7 in this
position and then if D4 takes takes uh
we get the same same sort of
variation uh now this was played in the
US championship last year a Wonder leing
played this as SP against favano Carana
I think favano played Bishop B5 here uh
but he wasn't able to win against a
Wonder like a Wonder held him to a draw
so even though the grandmas
this line is uh is
playable um now going back to what
happened in the
game after takes I want to clean Pawn
but I don't think I handled things
correctly maybe bishop B5 was was not
the right approach maybe here I should
have played C3 because after D5 yeah my
opponent
played I think very nicely to to make
things
messy and then even though I was up a
couple Pawns I was behind
development I was only up a pawn
here castling was very
interesting but I think around here like
once I played Rook C1 I was
consolidating and then managed to put on
the
pressure so um we're 13 minutes in how
about I do one more game for this
episode I rated 652 now do a new
game
now playing King Klyde white again okay
I'll play E4 are we going to have the
same
opening no we have a a more standard
Knight C6 I'll play the italion bishop
C4 Knight F6 and Bishop C5 are the two
most common
moves and here I'll play
D3 I played this in the the previous
episode one of the most solid moves not
going into the Knight G5 lines which are
playable
but maybe I'll save them for future
opponents so we see kind of a a weird
move Knight
B4 which definitely violates a few
principles like it's moving away from
the center it's not really attacking
anything it's also moving the same piece
twice and it's leaving the pawn on E5
undefended so going to show no mercy
here
hopefully in this game I can uh more
cleanly
convert the the early extra Pawn
Advantage nice thing about Knight takes
E5 is now I'm threatening Knight takes
F7 or Bishop takes
F7 so black has to be very very
careful I think the only reasonable move
is Pawn
D5 which we do
see I wonder if this is like some weird
prepar Gambit like open the center and
try and exploit my
knight but I think everything is under
control I can
take and there's actually a cool idea if
black if black were to play Queen E7 I
would have castled said oh no my knight
and then Rook E1 would win the
queen very common Motif when the E files
open uh in this case I think I'm still
happy to
Castle
and it was tempting to maybe consider
Queen F3 but I think it's better to get
the king safe have the option for Rook
E1 or queen F3 next
move and yeah the downside of this
Knight coming into my territory and not
really attacking anything anytime I want
I can play a move like A3 and black will
have to spend time moving
back
so here yeah my knight seems to be
attacked but I don't need to defend it
because I have rookie
one so I could like be tricky and play a
move that doesn't defend the
knights but I think in this case like
Rook E1 it's just a good move to
include like Rooks are happy on open
files I'm also aligning with a king
which is not castled
yet black should definitely put a bishop
like on E6 or
E7 if we see Bishop E7 or Bishop E6 and
it still takes work for
white I was thinking about Queen F3
hitting the pawn
but I don't want to make things messy
like Queen F3 there's Knight takes C 2
and even if I win
F7 and that line could be good for white
but generally when you're up material
you want to try and keep things
simple so I would very much like to
develop I like the move Knight
C3 just applying more pressure to the
center in some sense this Knight is
pinned to the F7
Pawn so if black takes on C3
I can then take on
F7 and then capture
back but uh okay black is leaving the
Knight
here so if I take it's just a
trade yeah I'm looking for like the the
forcing move so obviously the capture is
on
D5 a move like Knight B5 attacking the
queen could be interesting
also A3 I don't think there's any like
easy way to win
material but I kind of like this move
A3 cuz if this Knight moves right away
then I just win the Knight on
D5 so black will probably have to take
first I'll take
back and then if we see a move like
Knight C6 I could either trade or
develop the bishop
but so far it's just been about kind of
keeping control making sure my pieces
are getting
optimized uh we see F6 so now yeah now
it looks complicated cuz both Knights
are hanging but if we simply think ahead
a couple moves I take this Knight black
takes this Knight then this Knight will
be
undefended Knight's also pinned after F6
so yeah black is asking for trouble
now do I want to take with the bishop or
the Knight I think both moves are
completely
acceptable drawn more towards taking
with the bishop just immediately
checking the
king and
now my Pawn is
attacked I could defend it or I could
just leave on
B4 and try and generate threats on the
king
side I think in this case there's no
reason to give back the pawn like Queen
H5 is
tempting but then Queen takes B4
and I'd rather just be materialistic at
least for a move hold on to the pawn and
there is a cool idea when I play B
B5 um I'm opening the fourth rank so
there are ideas of Rook A4 and then
swinging over
someday but after C6 okay I'll
take and now the bishop
can find a happy place on
e4 the bishop is very nice
here pressure is the king side but still
the queen side as well and yeah going
forward from here uh there
are a few different strategies and we've
seen a lot of cases throughout the
speedrun where I'm up material and the
strategy is usually either to trade or
to
attack I think this position probably
calls
for attacking just because yeah my queen
can come to H5 I'm already threatening
Maiden
one and I have the bishop other Bishop
both pointed towards the king
side there's also potential to lift The
Rook
over
there's not too many moves for black to
defend like sometimes pawn moves like H6
or G6 create more
weaknesses and the queen can't really
defend because my Bishops control G6 and
H6 so I think black has to move one of
these
pawns ooh okay so the king is trying to
run um now it's a choice do I take the
pawn with the queen or the
bishop and yeah one move is definitely
much more clearly winning than the other
and both moves are winning but uh it's
better to take with the bishop not
giving the chance chance for the king to
run to
F7 essentially forcing the king back
here and then it's a very simple Maiden
two we'll see if Checkmate plays out on
the
board
yeah so the key move here is Bishop
G6 discover check cutting off any
potential Queen blocks and controlling
F7 so after King G8 Queen H7 will be
Checkmate this maing pattern can come up
a lot in um especially in Kings side
attacks opponent taking their time but
yeah there's only one legal
move so I think this game
was definitely more controlled than the
first
game but uh yeah hopefully some lessons
to take away I mean my opponent
violated very clearly violated some
opening principles early on I won a pawn
but it still took work it was a matter
of kind of being patient improving
developing and then seizing the
opportunity to win material and then
understanding
that sometimes the best strategy is just
to go straight for the king yeah Queen
H5 if my opponent played a move like
H6 it still would have taken like
patience to win this like I can't sack
immediately because uh the queen can
take
back so I'm not sure what I would have
done like maybe a move like Bishop E3
just very solid developing
move um optimize further there's also an
idea like to maneuver the Knight Knight
E2 to G3 and maybe eventually to F5 as
the knight's not actually doing much on
C3 so sometimes in the middle game you
want to look for the pieces that aren't
doing much and try and make them do
something alternatively there's an idea
Bishop G6 and then Knight E4 to
centralize the Knight so yeah perhaps it
would have been of a fight if black play
played H6 or
G6 so we're about 25 minutes in I think
I'm going to wrap it up for this episode
hope you guys learned a thing or two if
you have questions or comments leave
them below and I'll see you guys soon
for episode 6 stay tuned